[Music]
do
it enters into existence only at that
point where it's pure knowledge about
itself
is the antithesis and alternation of its
dual aspect
aware that its pure knowledge is an
abstract essence absolute spirit
is this conscious duty and absolute
antithesis to the knowledge that is
conscious of itself
qua absolute individuality itself as
essence
the former is the pure continuity of the
universal which is aware that the
individuality which is conscious
of itself as essence is intrinsically a
nullity
is evil this however is the absolute
discreteness which is conscious
of itself in its pure oneness as
absolute
and of the universal as something unreal
which exists only for someone else
both aspects are purified into the unity
in which there is no longer in them any
existence devoid of self
any negative of consciousness where on
the contrary duty
is the unchanging identical character of
itself knowledge and evil
equally has its purpose in its being
within itself and its actuality in its
utterance
the content of this utterance is the
substance of its enduring existence it
is the assurance of spirits imminent
self-certainty
each of these two self certain spirits
has no other purpose
than its own pure self and no other
reality and existence than just this
pure self
but yet they are different and the
difference is absolute because it is set
in this element of the pure notion
it is also absolute not only for us but
for the notions themselves
which stand in this antithesis for these
notions those specific in relation to
one another
are at the same time in themselves
universal so that they fill out the
whole range of the self
and the self has no other content than
this its own determinateness
which neither goes beyond the self nor
is more restricted than it
for one of them the absolute universal
is equally the pure knowledge of itself
as the other is the absolute
discreetness of individuality
and both are only this pure self
knowledge
both determinatenesses are thus pure
conscious notions
whose determinateness is itself
immediately a knowing
or whose relationship in antithesis is
the eye
consequently they are these sheer
opposites for one another
it is the completely inner being which
thus confronts its own self
and enters into outer existence they
constitute pure knowledge which
through this antithesis is posited as
consciousness
but it is still not yet
self-consciousness it
becomes actually such in the movement of
this antithesis
for this antithesis is rather itself the
indiscreet continuity and identity of i
equals i and each through the very
contradiction of its pure universality
which at the same time still strives
against its identity with the other and
cuts itself off from it
explicitly supersedes itself within its
own self
through this externalization this
knowledge which in its essence
is self-discordant returns into the
unity of the self it is the actual
i the universal knowledge of itself in
its absolute opposite in the knowledge
which remains internal and which on
account of the purity of its separated
being within self
is itself completely universal the
reconciling
yay in which the two eyes let go of
their antithetical existence is the
existence of the eye
which is expanded into a duality and
therein remains identical with itself
and in its complete externalization and
opposite
possesses the certainty of itself it is
god manifested in the midst of those who
know themselves
in the form of pure knowledge
with paragraph 671 we now
find ourselves at a number of different
endpoints so we can talk first about
section c
conscience the beautiful soul evil and
its forgiveness which is run from
paragraph 632
to this last paragraph a long section in
which we've been doing a lot of things
but of course this is part of the larger
morality section of spirit
right and then we can talk about ending
the entire
portion of the work the longest portion
of the work
that is spirit and when we get into the
religion section we're going to see that
hegel
talks about consciousness
self-consciousness both of which were
relatively short in relation to reason
which is much longer and then spirit
which is even longer than that
as being these different threads that
are being brought together
in a knot and you notice that we've
covered a lot of the same ground
several times transforming it in the
process there is what
hegel calls sublation you know auf haven
that is is going on and so
it's you know it's not a surprise that
the ending
here is really bringing a lot of things
together
so we should you know remind ourselves
of
with this paragraph where we're starting
and where we're
ending because it prepares us for the
transition
into the next fairly sizable section
religion
so let's actually talk about that first
and think about the very last sentence
of this he tells us
it is god manifested in the midst of
those who know themselves
in the form of pure knowledge so what is
it well all these things that we're
going to talk about
in just a moment god manifested so we've
got
we've got the divine we've got whatever
the highest principle is
whatever has been running the show you
could say whatever it is that we're
trying
to align ourselves with or achieve
hegel is in indeed in his own you know
strange way
a theist and a christian thinker
and so this god we're going to have to
figure
out starting in the next section well
what is this this god that we're talking
about
it's not as if gods and conceptions of
god haven't come up
previously you might think about the
unhappy consciousness where all this
work is devoted to it or the earlier
parts of
the spirit section where we had you know
uh god's
uh and the the divine law in relation to
the law of the city
and all sorts of things like that so
we've got this
theological conception coming in
at the end where does he begin this
paragraph well where the other paragraph
leaves off
absolute spirit right and an absolute
for
hegel means something quite
important right you always want to have
the absolute if you can
most people in the course of the
dialectic don't have the absolute
even though they think at that point in
time that they are grasping the absolute
it's as if it's always you know evading
our grasp
and you know we're getting the absolute
here in this reconciliation between
these two
sides of consciousness that we've you
know essentially personified
as being polarities with each other but
we could see these
as within an individual or within
a group we can we can read this in a
number of different ways
so he begins by saying it absolute
spirit
enters into existence only at that point
where it's pure knowledge about itself
is
the antithesis and alternation
alternation there is vexil exchange the
the
changing back and forthful alternation
is fine
of and here miller inserts of its dual
aspect
you know its knowledge about itself is
the the antithesis and alternation of
itself
right so he goes on he says aware
that it's pure knowledge is an abstract
essence
absolute spirit is this conscious duty
an absolute antithesis to the knowledge
that is conscious of itself
qua absolute individuality itself as
essence so we've got we have two
essences here right abstract essence
uh individuality is essence we're gonna
hit on this a bit more
both of them can be understood as beings
but they can also understood as
as be understood as beings that are
essential that are important that matter
right that we should center our thought
upon and we have an antithesis a
contradiction
between them an opposition so this
happens
through knowledge that is conscious of
itself
right and this consciousness itself
is going to be central here as well
so far so good right none of this should
be unfamiliar to
people who've traversed the gallian uh
dialectic
up to this point so he goes on and then
he says
the former okay so what is the former
this
at you know uh abstract essence absolute
spirit as
conscious duty um the former is the pure
continuity of the universal
which is aware that the individuality
which is conscious of itself
as essence is intrinsically a nullity
is evil so let's pause on that for a
moment
the universal consciousness
now we've got this reconciliation that's
taken place the side of the universal
thinking things in terms of the
universal and this could be the
universal within you
as you're thinking about an action that
you're doing and you're like considering
the sides of the action that aren't
quite so savory or have bad effects
insofar as action happens it has to be
by individuals it has to be individual
it has to be made real
and in so far as it's made real veer
click actual
it winds up being in discordance
with the universal we've seen this play
itself out in many different ways not
just in the spirit section
not just in this morality section but
even in the reason section as well
so evil evil is
individuality opposed to the
universality and opposed to the
universality not merely as
value but the universality as
consciousness and we could talk here
not just about simple polarities but
maybe like a spectrum
right and you fall somewhere in that
depending on how well you're reconciled
with or harmonized with or integrated
into
the community so he goes on and he says
the this is a pure continuity of the
individual the universal
where the individuality is evil this
however the individual is the absolute
discreteness
which is conscious of itself in its pure
oneness
as absolute so
again rehashing stuff
insofar as we're acting
we have to act as individuals if we're
going to do our duties
we take upon ourselves this is why
conscience was so important
we take upon ourselves boldly
or in in fear and trembling this
responsibility of acting and
as hegel points out and i this is a
really important point for for hegel
something that often gets lost sight of
in in his works
that here we go the the absolute
discreetness
is aware of itself uh as you know as
absolute
and of the universal as something
unreal now here's where here's a really
interesting phrase
which exists only for someone else who's
this someone else
well it is also you know the the self
but it could be framed in a different
way the universal
exists only for itself
and for another it exists as an
abstraction
as something that we don't actually
have to have as something that
you know once we've got the raw material
of this abstraction perhaps we could
dispense with it perhaps it doesn't
actually help to help us in
acting when we jump into the situation
where we've got determinate
circumstances and we're going to be
using this word determinate
in a little bit um does the universal
really help us or
is it an impediment is there a risk of
turning into the beautiful
soul that pretends that it's somehow
acting by thinking or feeling or talking
or ineffective willing so this is this
is a really important realization here
right
he goes on and he says here's where we
have this reconciliation taking place
both aspects are purified into
the unity there's a unity going on here
that
we've been seeking this entire time and
now is actually happening
a unity a unity
in which there's no longer in them any
existence devoid of self
any negative of consciousness where
now this is going from both sides on the
contrary duty
is the unchanging identical character of
itself
knowledge and now notice what he says
here
evil equally has its purpose
in its being within itself and its
actuality and its utterance
so what we were framing as evil before
in terms of individuality as opposed
acting
choosing imperfectly as opposed to the
universal
consciousness of duty even evil
has its place within this
and you could you know think about this
in a number of different ways without
evil we couldn't have gotten to this
point
right we couldn't have gotten to the
admission
of evil within its own self on the part
of the individual consciousness
we couldn't have gotten to the eventual
forgiveness of evil
by the part of the universal
consciousness which certainly took its
time to do so
didn't it right
evil associated with individuality
perhaps with defect with
disruption with destruction with malice
with selfishness
somehow gets integrated into this
and we could think again of that phrase
that came up a few paragraphs earlier
the wounds of the spirit
heal without leaving any scars
now this is a part of hegel's
uh you know phenomenology and other work
that that many people have pointed at
and said
i don't know if i want to buy into this
that somehow evil can be brought
into this this framework you know it's
almost like a theodicy where everything
becomes
you know not so bad and we we don't
acknowledge evil as evil but he's not
saying that he's saying
evil has its purpose it's its
end in being within itself in actuality
in its utterance
what is the content of this utterance
the substance of its enduring existence
it is the assurance of spirits imminent
self-certainty you know that's a lot of
jargon there what
does he mean um the assurance of spirits
imminent self-certainty
whatever's happening at this stage of
the dialectic is more than just
an individual being evil doing some
stuff
that could be good but it's actually
also bad
there's something more going on here
that is being
taken up that is being transformed
he goes on and now here we get to these
interesting
parallels and characterizations of these
two different polarities so he says each
of these and he calls them
two self-certain spirits
so we have a geist spirits we have
absolute spirit right and it's
it's encompassing both of these and the
relations between them
and their consciousness of those
relations and we could go on and on and
on
but we have a self-certain spirit on
this side and we also have a
self-certain spirit
on this side self-certainty you know
conscience give you a sight right and
and
uh self-knowledge is
on both of these sides and we've
achieved the point where there's a
recognition a mutual recognition
going on between the two so it sounds
like they're you know
basically the same kind of thing just on
different
sides different polarities that are
connected with each other
so he says each of them has no other
purpose
than its own pure self
and no other reality and existence
than just this pure self three important
terms here
purpose reality
existence now
if you've been following along you
should
say to yourself wait a second okay i get
that both of them have
purposes zvec right n's goals
what they're intending but wasn't
reality
and existence vehicle kite diazine on
the side of the individual consciousness
how did universal consciousness get that
well
for a variety of reasons as we've seen
universal consciousness is also
individuated right
there's no individual consciousness sort
of fl
or universal consciousness floating
around out there
it's it's in a person who just happens
to
stand in for the universal and they have
a reality and
they have an existence and these are
both being
uh acknowledged now so he says the
content of this utterance
right each of these two cells certain
spirits has no other purpose
than than its own pure self uh and he
goes on and says yet they are
different and the difference is absolute
because it is set in this element of the
pure notion
okay so notion concept begrave
right each of them is different and the
difference is
absolute so they're not identical
there is mutual recognition taking place
between two things that are
grasping each other is same and yet
different
right and he tells us that each of these
is also a specific
notion or concept he goes on here and he
says
this pure notion is absolute not only
for us but for the notions
themselves which stand in this
antithesis
in this opposition so there's a pure
notion governing this entire thing
pure concept that is working itself out
this is the absolute spirit
right and it can be grasped by
either side but they also are grasping
themselves
as notions or concepts
as well and as being different from each
other
and as being specific now here's where
it gets really interesting right
these are self-consciousnesses they're
not just
you know notions they're not just spirit
they're self-consciousnesses they are
specific
in relation to the other so they have
their
you know um zonderheit uh in
in their connection in their being in
uh connection with the other and
the you know this is a gigan ain't under
right
so instead of just saying in bedziong
right
uh gegen ein ander in opposition
to each other because then the
antithesis is giganzotz
so they stand in antithesis to each
other
um there's unity and there's also
differentiation
and there's also still being in the kind
of tension
a contradiction with each other so he
goes on and he says
they are specific in relation to one
another they are at the same time in
themselves universal so that they fill
out the whole range of the self
and this self has no other content than
its own determinateness which neither
goes beyond the self
nor is more restricted than it for one
of them the absolute universal is
equally the pure knowledge of itself
as the other is the absolute
discreetness of individuality
both are only this pure self-knowledge
both of them are involved in
self-knowledge their knowledge of
themselves their knowledge of themselves
in relation to the other their knowledge
of themselves is something
more because of that relation to the
other
now when hegel is saying that there's
nothing outside of
they fill out the whole range of
themselves
they don't go beyond the self is nor is
more restricted than it okay does this
mean that we have sort of like a
solipsistic conception here no because
we have
not just one individual we have
two individuals and this can be writ
large throughout
a society where different people are
standing in for this
and this is also a polarity within
individuals existing individuals as well
right now he goes on and he says
both determinatenesses are thus pure
conscious
notions whose determinateness is itself
immediately unknowing
right by being what they are they know
themselves for
what they are and then he says or whose
relationship in antithesis
is the the i
now here we're getting into the third
part of this paragraph
so he says consequently they are these
shear opposites for each other it is the
completely inner being which confronts
its own self
and enters into outer existence they
constitute pure knowledge which through
this antithesis
is posited as consciousness and then he
says something kind of weird here
right for something that's concluding
the set the the ending
but it is still not yet
self-consciousness it becomes
actually such in the movement of this
antithesis
so what is a movement of an antithesis
right
okay antithesis two things are opposed
to each other they're different from
each other
they're connected with each other in
this case we have consciousnesses
that are connected with each other they
are self-consciousnesses and they're
that
they're related to each other but
they're not yet realizing themselves
fully as self-consciousnesses in this
antithesis
the i is not yet realized
as such although you know we're
certainly making some progress here
he goes on this antithesis
is rather the indiscrete continuity and
identity of i
equals i now every time that we've had
an i equals i we got something pretty
abstract there right
and hegel says we have to have a
transformation we have to have a
movement
from what so he says each through the
very contradiction of its pure
universality
which at the same time still strives
against its identity with the other and
cuts itself off from it so there's still
tension going on here
right there's still opposition
explicitly supersedes itself within its
own self so each side
is superseding itself each side is
overcoming you know elf haven right
it's itself and thereby
they're doing it together but
differently
and recognition can can take
place so he calls this an
externalization
this knowledge which is in its existence
this knowledge which in its existence is
self-discordant returns to the unity of
the self
it is the actual i the universal
knowledge of itself in its absolute
opposite
in the knowledge which remains internal
and which on the account of the purity
of its separated being in itself
is itself completely universal the
reconciling
yay affirmation right
in which the two eyes let go their
antithetical existence
is the existence of the eye which is
expanded into a duality so
both of these sides are this is part of
what it means for them to supersede
themselves
they are still in opposition but that
opposition is no longer something
that deprives them of something they're
able to mutually recognize
each other and get from the other what
it is that they
they need and therefore produce an
affirmation
so he goes on and says
the reconciling ea in which these two
eyes let go their their antithetical
existence
is the existence of the eye the actual
eye
which is expanded into a duality therein
remains identical with itself
and in its complete externalization and
opposite
possesses certainty of itself and here's
where he calls this
god manifested in the midst of those who
know themselves in the form of pure
knowledge so we've
attained something divine in the process
and now the question that we have to ask
as we end this
which is going to be answered by the
religion section is not just
well what is this divine can you give it
some content can you tell me about what
what the hell this divine that all this
back and forth stuff throughout the
whole spirit section has led us into
it's also about what am i
in relation to that divine what
who am i what kind of thing am i
how do i know how do i feel how do i
connect myself to this divine
and that is where this spirit section is
ending
with something again very abstract not
filled in
and that's where we move into the next
section
which is uh quite a bit shorter uh this
religion
section right in comparison to all the
others but there's going to be a lot of
dialectical development
going on there we're getting close to
the end of the work
and with this we end the spirit section
this may
in fact not feel entirely
resolved to you and you may
be you know saying i don't you know this
seems still very abstract i'm not quite
sure
what's going on that is a perfectly
natural and normal reaction i think
to what hegel has done here i don't know
that you're meant to be satisfied
reaching the end of this this section i
don't know that hegel himself was
actually
all that satisfied that's why we have
more going on
in the two sections to come
you